Professor Mark Saltzman:
So, this week we're going
to talk about drug delivery,
this is Chapter 14.
This is an example of what I
call in the textbook
Biomolecular Engineering.
This is one of my favorite
weeks of the course because this
is my research specialty,
is drug delivery.
What I want to do today,
Thursday, and then we'll
continue in section is today I'm
going to sort of set up the
problem,
talk about some definitions to
think about, if one is building
drug delivery systems,
think about some basic concepts
in drug delivery.
We're going to do that by
thinking about sort of common
modes of drug administration and
why some of them work with some
drugs and not with others,
sort of lay the foundations
today.
Then, on Thursday we'll talk
about what's new in drug
delivery and what things you can
expect in the future,
things that are still being
built and then you'll get to
make some drug delivery systems
in section on Thursday
afternoon.
This is really a logical
extension of what we started
talking about last week when we
moved from talking about the
immune system and how it
operates to administration
intentionally of vaccines to
alter the immune system or to
change your body's response.
In some senses,
you could think about delivery
of a vaccine like delivery of a
drug or introducing something
not naturally in the body--into
the body in order to have some
kind of biological effect.
It's the same thing as delivery
of a drug.
And we also thought about
delivery in a variety of ways:
we thought about injection of
vaccines like the smallpox
vaccine,
we thought about oral
administration of vaccine,
in the case of the oral polio
vaccine.
So, I just wanted to show you
this picture to remind you that
you already know something about
drug delivery.
What we're going to talk about
is an extension of what we
started talking about last week.
Now, in the case of a
vaccine, you'll remember,
that the intent was to
administer either proteins,
usually proteins or whole
viruses, or we talked at the end
of the class on Thursday about
administering DNA with the
intention that you're going to
bring some new molecules into a
special class of cells called
antigen presenting cells.
That those antigen presenting
cells are going to be changed as
a result of their experience
with this vaccine such that they
present new molecules on their
surface,
that's the change that comes
about.
Then, that change in this cell
is going to stimulate changes in
other cells.
If humoral immune response or
antibody mediated immune
response is generated,
then the change in antigen
presenting cells is going to
influence B-cells to
differentiate and proliferate,
etc.
This is an example of a
very particular example of what
happens when you administer a
drug as well.
Chemicals are introduced into
the body, the intent is usually
to make some kind of a
biochemical change in cells or
maybe many cells in your body
such that they're function is
altered in some way that's
helpful to you.
We didn't really talk about it
last week, but in some cases
immunization really is like drug
delivery.
Particularly,
in the case of what's called
passive immunization,
where instead of introducing a
pathogen or a piece of a
pathogen to an individual you
actually make antibodies outside
of the individual.
So, manufacture them in some
ways, and we talked about ways
of manufacturing antibodies a
few weeks ago.
Then introduce those antibodies
themselves into the person to
provide protection against
whatever pathogen those
antibodies are directed against.
If any of you have traveled
to areas of the world where
Hepatitis A is common,
in parts of Asia for example,
you might have gotten a shot of
gamma globulin which is really
just antibodies that are
enriched for anti-Hepatitis A
activity.
Now, the difference between
that and a vaccine is that that
dose of antibodies only lasts
for a certain length of time,
about 30 to 60 days.
So, you have to get the shot 30
to 60 days before you're going
to be in the area where you're
exposed.
The same way we're going to
think a lot about the timing of
drugs, how long do their effects
last,
what determines how long they
last, and what does it mean if
you still need the drug when its
effect is gone,
how does taking subsequent
quantities of the drug effect
its concentration in your body,
for example.
I'm going to start with
some definitions and I realize
that you can read this on your
own.
Hopefully you already have read
some of this in the chapter,
but just to make sure that we
have the vocabulary right,
and some of these are words
that you're familiar with like
drug.
A drug is any molecule which
can be introduced into the body,
which alters body function on a
molecular level.
You're used to thinking about
drugs you might take for a
headache like aspirin or
Ibuprofen.
Or if you asthma,
for example,
you might take drugs that
affect your bronchioles or the
pathways--the airways in your
lung by dilating them so it's
easier to get air in and out.
These are molecules which are
introduced into the body;
they make some kind of change
in the body on a molecular
level.
Pharmacology is the science
of dealing with these
interactions of molecules that
are introduced into the body.
They're usually molecules that
are generated from outside the
body, maybe synthesized in some
way.
They might be molecules that
are not ordinarily found in our
bodies, but are known to have
some effects.
They might be derivatives of
molecules that are naturally
found in our bodies.
For example,
Parkinson's disease is treated
by a derivative of the
neurotransmitter Dopamine.
You're introducing something
that looks very much like a
natural molecule back into the
body to have an effect.
Toxicology is that branch
of pharmacology that thinks
exclusively about toxic effects
of the drug.
One of the main challenges with
developing drugs and drug
delivery systems is that drugs
have unwanted effects.
They have the effect that you
desire at the tissue or within
the cells that they were
designed to affect,
but they can also effects in
other parts of the body and
those effects are side-effects.
Those effects are toxicities or
unwanted changes in the body as
a result of the drug.
We're going to talk about
two important different but
related concepts called
pharmacodynamics and
pharmacokinetics.
Pharmacodynamics is the effect
of a drug on a body and it's
usually on the body or on cells
from the body.
It's usually defined by a
dose-response curve.
Dose response means I give a
certain amount of the drug and I
see what effect it has.
I give more,
I see what effect that has,
I give more I see what effect
that has.
You can imagine that's a very
important thing to define for
any drug because you want to
deliver the minimum dose that's
needed to produce the desired
effect.
You don't want to introduce any
more than necessary.
So, understanding the
relationship between dose
delivered and biological
response is very important.
Often that's done first on
cells in culture,
for example.
You want to understand how a
chemotherapy agent,
a potential agent for treating
tumors will affect tumors in a
person.
The first thing you do is you
might have cultured tumor cells
and you expose those cells to
different concentrations of the
drug and you see at what dose do
I begin to see cell death or
killing of the tumor cells.
That's one kind of dose
response relationship.
Now, you could understand,
probably, that that might be
very different if you administer
that same dose into a person.
We're going to talk about why
dose responses in people are
different than dose responses in
cell cultures,
or in more artificial systems.
The pharmacodynamic effect
of a drug, or the study of
pharmacodynamics,
is 'what does the drug do to
the body?
' Usually that's defined at
specific doses,
what does it do.
Pharmacokinetics has to do with
how your body handles the drug.
The body has exquisite
mechanisms for getting rid of
molecules.
Molecules that are produced
naturally in your body only have
a certain lifetime.
Likewise, antibodies that
we--molecules that we introduced
from outside the body also have
a lifetime,
and that depends on the
mechanism that your body uses to
get rid of the compound.
Well, that manner in which the
body handles a drug,
how the body changes the drug,
how it excretes the drug is
called pharmacokinetics and that
has to do with what the body
does to the drug,
not what the drug does to the
body.
That's the easiest way to think
about it.
One pharmacokinetic concept
that's very important is the
concept of bioavailability.
If I have a dose of the drug,
let's say 100 milligrams of a
drug, and I administer it to an
individual,
then how much of that drug
actually gets into the body
where it can be useful?
Bioavailability is going to
depend on how we administer the
drug.
If we administer it orally
versus inject it intravenously,
versus some of the other routes
of administration we'll talk
about in a few minutes.
The main effect of changing the
route of administration is to
change the bioavailability or
how much of the drug actually
reaches the active sites.
A related concept is
biotransformation.
Biotransformation refers to all
the mechanisms that your body
could use to convert a drug into
something else.
Often, that conversion of a
drug into something else is an
important part of how your body
gets rid of a drug.
Many biotransformation
reactions happen in the liver.
The liver is a very active site
of metabolism and chemical
reaction.
Many drugs that we take are
converted into other compounds
in the liver,
by cells in the liver.
Often, this conversion into
another compound is the first
step in your body getting rid of
it;
sometimes it's the only step.
Sometimes your liver is able to
convert a molecule into
something that's completely
inactive.
For example,
if you take alcohol,
which is a drug,
it's converted in the liver
into other molecules which don't
have the biological effect of
alcohol.
It's done by enzymes in liver
cells, including the enzyme
alcohol dehydrogenase.
Sometimes--we won't talk so
much about this but I want you
to at least realize it,
is that sometimes we deliver
molecules that are inactive but
don't have any response.
Your body doesn't have any
response to them,
but we deliver them knowing
that your liver is going to
convert them into something
active,
that they're going to be
biotransformed by some chemical
reaction into an active
compound.
So, it's another aspect of
biotransformation.
I want to spend the next 15
or 20 minutes or so talking
about how drugs are
administered.
In particular,
that question should be why are
they administered in different
ways?
Why is Ibuprofen taken orally,
for example,
but some antibiotics or
chemotherapy drugs have to be
injected directly into the
bloodstream.
Why is that do you think?
Why are some drugs administered
in different ways?
It could be that you're
targeting different parts of the
body and so you want to deliver
them at their site of action,
that might be one reason to do
it.
There what are you changing?
You're changing the potential
for side-effects really,
or the potential for toxicity
of the drug.
If you can deliver more at the
site of action then less of it
goes to the rest of the body
where it might cause unwanted
effects,
so that's a very good reason to
target it.
Student:
[inaudible]Professor Mark
Saltzman: Sometimes there
are biological barriers to drugs
entering different parts of the
body.
We're going to start by talking
about the body as sort of a
single unit or compartment.
When I introduce drugs into
them those drugs are available
everywhere, but that's not true.
There are some parts of the
body that are protected from
entry of drugs,
and the brain is the most
famous of those parts of the
body that are protected.
It makes sense that the brain
is protected,
because the function of the
brain depends on the balance of
chemical concentrations within
it,
the concentrations of ions and
neurotransmitters,
and any molecules that could
potentially interfere with ions
or neurotransmitters.
Our brain chemistry has to be
very tightly regulated in order
for us to stay awake and pay
attention and do the things that
we normally do.
In contrast,
the chemistry in our blood is
changing throughout the day.
After you eat chemistry changes
because molecules are absorbed
from the intestine,
and as those molecules get
processed by the body
concentration in the blood
changes.
If your brain chemistry was
changing in that same way,
then you'd be slipping in and
out of consciousness and you
notice that you do a little bit
right after lunch.
It's a little bit harder to pay
attention than before lunch
because the chemistry is
changing,
but that change in chemistry is
muted by the blood brain barrier
or the fact that molecules can't
get very easily into the brain.
Why else might drugs be
administered in different ways?
Think about insulin,
what do you know about insulin
as a drug?
Student:
[inaudible]Professor Mark
Saltzman: Speed of action is
an important thing and we're
going to talk in a few minutes
about some drugs where onset of
action is very important.
It needs to act very quickly
and the way that you administer
it has as big effect on how
rapidly concentrations in the
body rise.
So, some things you need to act
very rapidly,
you'll pick the mode of
administration to do that.
There's another issue with
insulin which we'll come too,
keep that one in mind.
This is a table that's in
the book and I want to go
through it relatively quickly
because I think you can read it
and it's pretty understandable
on its own.
I want to use these specific
examples of different routes of
administration to think about
the answer to this question,'
why are drugs administered in
different ways?
' More importantly,
to think about the biology or
the physiology of your body that
leads to these alternate forms
of administration.
One mode is intravenous
injection and we're going to
talk --there are different kinds
of injection.
You can put a needle into
different parts of the body.
You can put it into a muscle,
you can put it under the skin,
you can put it actually into
the spinal fluid that surrounds
your spinal cord.
Intravenous injection refers
specifically to a needle that's
placed within the
bloodstream--within a vein,
and so drugs are introduced
directly into the bloodstream.
The advantages of that should
be obvious.
That's what was related to
Caitlin's comment,
that drug is immediately
introduced into the blood,
and so it's immediately
distributed throughout your body
and available for action
wherever it's needed.
So, onset of action is very
rapid.
In addition,
its bioavailability is 100%.
We've introduced the drug into
the blood directly,
into your circulatory flow,
so all of the molecules that
are administered to the patient
are available for action.
Now, usually we think about
bioavailability as the fraction
of the drug that ends up in the
blood and you might say,
'well but that might not be
where the drug acts'.
The drug might act in the brain
or it might act in the kidney,
or it might act in your muscles
and being in the blood is not
the same as being in those
tissues,
and you're right.
It's hard to measure those
concentrations in individual
tissues and so we define
bioavailability as the fraction
of a drug dose that gets into
the blood.
Now, why wouldn't we do
intravenous administration for
everything?
Because if it is fast,
usually you don't want to wait
for--you want the drug to act as
rapidly as possible and you'd
like all the drug molecules to
be bioavailable,
you would like all of them to
be useful.
So, why don't we use
intravenous administration all
the time?
Well, it probably is obvious
that not--that it's not so easy
to do.
That in general,
safe intravenous administration
requires trained medical
personnel.
So, usually you're in a
doctor's office or a hospital,
you don't do it yourself at
home.
There is a risk because you're
introducing drugs at high
concentration into the blood.
There's much more risk of
overdose or toxicity because the
concentration's going to change
very rapidly.
Even though you might know what
the average response to a drug
is, average among a population
of people,
we're all different in ways
that are important to how drugs
act.
You know this,
if you take Ibuprofen,
you read the dosage on the
label, it will say something
like 'if you're over 12 years
old you take one dose and if
you're under 12 you take another
dose.'
So, size of the person or age
of the person is an important
determinant of how much dose you
take.
Gender is often an important
determinant, your overall state
of health is an important
determinant, and you can't know
those things for everybody.
You could go on and on in this
list and so you--one individual
might be more sensitive to doses
of the drug than another.
If you're introducing all the
drug at one time intravenously
the potential for an unwanted
response is higher.
It's a risk of infection
because you're introducing
something directly into the
bloodstream if it's not done
properly, and it's not
comfortable.
Most people don't want to have
an intravenous injection.
So, you might not do it in
cases where even if it would
benefit you, and so those are
disadvantages.
It's a very safe and effective,
and useful mode of
administration for some kinds of
compounds.
For example,
for antibiotics,
if you happen to have what's
called sepsis or an infection
that's spread into your
bloodstream,
one of the only ways to combat
those infections effectively is
to introduce antibiotics
directly into the bloodstream.
Intravenous infusion is a
similar mode,
but now instead of a onetime
injection,
with an intravenous injection
you have a syringe full of drug,
a needle in the circulatory
system,
and you introduce the drug all
at once, in infusion you slowly
pump the drug in and you might
be pumping it in continuously
over a long period time,
maybe over hours or over days.
Sometimes this is done--you've
seen on TV shows a bag of a
solution hanging up on a pole
and a tube going into a
patient's arm.
So, this is an infusion where
the infusion is driven by the
gravity flow of fluid through
the tube into the patient's
blood vessel,
that's one example of an
infusion.
Other examples are there
might be pump involved at some
point.
You have a pump in between the
bag of fluid and the needle that
goes into the arm.
In this way,
you can control the flow much
more carefully.
One example of where that's
done in the hospital is the
molecule Heparin,
which is an anticoagulant.
It's needed for certain
patients who are at risk of
having blood clots,
for example.
This might be--they might be at
risk for blood clots for a
variety of reasons,
but you introduce the molecule
Heparin which reduces the
likelihood that clots will form,
only you need to have a
continuous level of Heparin.
You need to have that Heparin
concentration continuously at
some level, and so you
continuously infuse it directly
into the circulatory system.
Now, this is a very effective
method for administering drugs
because you're slowly adding the
drug and you're watching to see
what concentration is maintained
in the person,
and you're adjusting the rate
by tuning the pump until you get
exactly the concentration that
you want.
You can leave it there and as
long as the patient stays
roughly the same,
then their concentration will
remain roughly the same.
So, you can expose them to a
drug over a long period of time
and have a biological effect
that's constant over a long
period of time.
That's very useful in certain
situations like this one I've
mentioned.
Again, it's 100%
bioavailable and you have
continuous control over plasma
levels.
For example,
what if you knew that the
patient was more at risk of
developing blood clots at night?
Well, then you'd put a
programmable pump on it,
and you'd program the pump so
that the rate of infusion
increased during the night and
then went down again in the
morning.
In that way you could increase
the concentration of drug at
night and then decrease it
during the day.
So, you'd only be using the
amount of drug that was needed
for a biological effect and
you'd be adjusting that
biological effect for the needs
of the patient in a very sort of
interactive way.
You can imagine,
now, extending that very simple
approach with a needle in the
bloodstream and a pump,
and a reservoir of fluid to
deliver any pattern of drug that
was needed for that individual.
Why isn't that done all the
time?
Well, for the same reasons the
intravenous infusion aren't done
all the time,
plus some, because this is even
more complex,
right?
So it requires continuous
monitoring and so there have to
be people there in case there is
some unexpected event in order
to turn off the pump or to
adjust the flow.
So, that really requires
hospitalization in most cases.
Now, we're going to get to the
point next time where we talk
about some examples of infusion
using pumps that can be worn by
individuals that can leave the
hospital with these pumps either
implanted within them or
strapped to their belt,
for example.
In general, that's done only in
unusual situations.
Subcutaneous injection and
intramuscular injection are
similar to intravenous injection
in that it's an injection from a
needle.
It's a onetime introduce the
drug all at once,
but you're putting the needle
in a different place.
Instead of intentionally
putting the needle into a vein
so that you introduce drug into
the blood,
you put it either in a muscle,
like a muscle mass of your arm,
or your back side.
Have you ever had an injection
there?
They don't do this so commonly
anymore, I'm not sure why.
I can imagine why but--into a
muscle mass and then the
molecules are absorbed from that
muscle into the blood or
subcutaneously--is subcutaneous,
cutaneous is skin,
sub is under,
this is an injection under the
skin.
So, you could pull up on your
skin a little flap,
you can sort of pull it away
from the muscle and you'd insert
the needle under there and
introduce a little reservoir of
drug solution underneath the
skin.
Now, this is how diabetics
administer insulin to
themselves, usually.
They put a needle into the
muscle and they inject a volume
of an insulin-containing
solution into the muscle space.
I say on this sheet here that
bioavailability in that case is
usually high,
why is it--who do you think
bioavailability is high for
these particular modes?
Why is it high for
intramuscular injection?
It might be 80% or 90%,
so it's not 100% but it's
pretty high, why is that?
How does the drug get into the
blood from there if I inject it
into muscle?
Justin?Student:
[inaudible]Professor Mark
Saltzman: Yeah,
so your muscle is being
perfused by blood all the time.
It gets blood flow,
there's arteries going in,
capillary networks,
and veins that are collecting
blood so there's a very rich
blood supply in muscle.
So, you inject it into the
muscle tissue and the drug just
sort of percolates in or
diffuses into the blood vessels
that are already there.
Now, the effects tend to last
longer than an intravenous
administration because it takes
some time for the drugs to move
from this reservoir where you've
injected them,
this little depot in the
muscle, it takes some time for
the drugs to move into your
bloodstream.
So, you get a prolonged effect
because of that;
not all the drug is available
at once.
You also don't get all the
drug in because some of it is
metabolized locally or it
doesn't go into the blood
vessels at all and so it doesn't
get distributed.
So, bioavailabilities not 100%
but it's often pretty high.
It's not as hazardous because
you're not actually introducing
a needle into a vein.
It can be done by individuals
at home and so diabetics can do
this;
they can do it several times a
day.
It's still uncomfortable,
most people don't want to do it
and you wouldn't do it if there
was an alternative.
Why is there no alternative for
insulin?
Why do diabetics do it this way?
Why do they inject insulin in
this way?
I think most of you can
understand that they would
prefer not to,
what would they prefer to do?
If you were a diabetic patient
and you needed insulin what
would you prefer to do?
Kate?Student:
Orally.Professor Mark
Saltzman: You'd prefer to
take a pill, right?
You prefer to take a pill and
that's the next one on the list,
is oral administration.
You prefer to take a pill but
you can't with insulin because
insulin is a protein.
Insulin is a protein that is
digested in the intestinal
tract.
That's one of the functions of
our gut, is to digest foods that
we eat, foods that contain
proteins for example.
So, your intestinal system is
very efficient at breaking down
proteins into their constituent
amino acids,
and it does that so that you
can extract amino acids from
food and use them for other
things.
If a protein is a drug,
you need it to enter the
bloodstream without being broken
down.
When it's broken down it
doesn't have the effect any
longer.
So, insulin can't be delivered
orally, primarily because it's
digested within the stomach and
small intestine before it's
absorbed.
Another problem with developing
a pill or oral forms of insulin
is that large molecules like
insulin,
which is a protein,
has a molecule weight of about
5,000 are not absorbed very
easily through the intestinal
wall.
We talked about this several
weeks ago, your intestinal wall
is a--it's a tube that the
surface of the tube is made up
of a continuous sheet or
monolayer of cells and these
cells are connected by tight
junctions.
Remember that picture I showed
you several weeks ago?
Because of that for a molecule
to enter it has to be able to go
through that monolayer of cells.
Even if insulin wasn't broken
down to its constituent
molecules it couldn't be
absorbed very easily because
it's a large molecule.
Only molecules that are small
and relatively lipid soluble can
go through monolayers of cells
like the epithelium of the
intestine.
There's two reasons why insulin
is not very bioavailable when
it's given orally.
That's one way of saying
insulin doesn't end up in the
blood, insulin is not
bioavailable when delivered
orally.
Some drugs are aspirin,
acetaminophen,
Ibuprofen, things that you
might take routinely for muscle
aches or headaches are available
orally.
They're small molecules,
they aren't digested
appreciably or only a fraction
of them are digested so that if
you take ten milligrams,
maybe five milligrams of them
are not broken down in the gut
and can be absorbed.
One of the problems with oral
administration is that drugs are
degraded before they're absorbed
into the body.
Now, we could tolerate that
with aspirin,
and why do you think that's
acceptable with aspirin to have
some fraction of it broken down
in the body--broken down in the
gut before it's absorbed?
Why is that acceptable?
How much does aspirin cost?
Student:
[inaudible]Professor Mark
Saltzman: Not very much,
you don't think about it when
you go buy a couple of tablets
of aspirin,
you go buy a bottle of aspirin
or Ibuprofen because it costs
something but it doesn't cost so
much.
So, if you had to pay two times
as much because you lost half of
it, because it was degraded
before it got absorbed,
that might be okay.
You're more likely to use it
because it's a pill and not an
injection and you're willing to
pay more for that convenience.
Often, drugs that are orally
administered,
they're not 100% bioavailable,
only a fraction of it gets into
your blood,
but they're molecules that can
be produced cheaply enough that
you can still take a dose that's
larger than what you would need,
knowing that half of it is not
going to enter your body.
Does that make sense?
The other thing about
aspirin is that it's not--I'll
use aspirin as an example,
realizing that nobody uses
aspirin for headaches anymore,
but it's a good example because
it's a molecule that's very
safe.
A safe drug is one in which the
concentration at which it causes
toxic effects is much higher
than the concentration at which
it causes good effects,
or the effect that you want.
We know in aspirin that if you
get your concentration up to a
certain level your headache will
go away.
You'd have to get a much higher
level in your blood before you
began to see side effects or
unwanted effects.
In aspirin those side effects
are that your ears start to ring
because it starts to effect
the--your mechanisms of hearing,
the cells within your cochlear
start to be affected by
concentrations of the drug at a
certain level.
You have to take a lot in
order to get up there.
This difference between an
effective dose and a toxic dose
is very important for drugs.
Drugs that have a big
difference between the safe dose
and the effective dose are ones
that you can give to patients
and trust them to take safely.
You could imagine if the toxic
dose was very close to the
effective dose that might not be
a drug that you would want to
have patients administering
themselves because what if they
accidentally take one too many
pills,
or they take them too close
together, they could produce
toxic side effects.
Aspirin is an example where you
have a big window between
effective and toxic.
Chemotherapy drugs are drugs
where there's a very narrow
window between effective and
toxic and so those are usually
given with the help and guidance
of a physician.
There's a similar mode of
administration called sublingual
or buckle.
Here, the drug is not
swallowed, it's taken in the
mouth but it's--but you hold the
pill or the capsule underneath
your tongue and you allow it to
dissolve there.
So, the drug enters your body
because it's absorbed through
the membranes in your mouth,
particularly the membranes
under your tongue.
This is a common mode of
administration for
nitroglycerin.
If you have grandparents or
friends who are older that have
certain kind of heart disease
where they get chest pain,
they might carry with them
tablets of nitroglycerin.
If they begin to experience
pain they'll put one of these
tablets underneath their tongue
and they'll let it dissolve.
There's a number of reasons
for doing this.
The most important one is that
when you're taking a drug
orally, you're taking advantage
of the mechanisms that your body
has for getting food and
nutrients,
and you're using those
mechanisms to get a drug.
When molecules are absorbed
through your intestine,
they go through the intestinal
wall, they enter the bloodstream
that surrounds the intestine.
Then, the way that your anatomy
is set up all of the blood flow
from your intestine goes
directly to your liver and from
your liver it goes back into the
vena cava and then to the heart.
Now, why would you design a
system like that,
where all the blood from your
intestine goes right to your
liver first?
Justin?Student:
[inaudible]Professor Mark
Saltzman: Purifying and
processing of the stuff that
comes from the intestine,
stuff like food,
nutrients that are extracted
from food, sugars,
fats, proteins that are
extracted from food that go to
your liver.
Why do they go to your liver?
Because your liver is a very
important metabolic organ and it
is important for processing
proteins and fats,
and sugars.
So, by sending all those
molecules that are absorbed from
the intestine to the liver
first,
you get a jump start on
processing of these molecules
into the substrates that you
need for life.
That's a really good set up for
nutrition, but I also mentioned,
remember that biotransformation
or breakdown of drugs often
occurs in the liver.
So, if drugs are absorbed the
same way that food is they go
right to the liver,
and--I'm pointing here because
that's where my liver is,
they go right to the liver and
your liver starts to break it
down right away before it even
gets to your bloodstream really,
before it circulates to the
rest of your body.
I lose a fraction of drug
because it's degraded within the
gut, I lose a fraction because
it can't absorb very rapidly,
and I lose another fraction
because the liver breaks it down
before it ever gets back to my
heart and then your heart can
circulate it.
Well, it turns out that the
blood supply to the membranes in
your mouth don't go to the
liver, it's unusual.
They go directly into the
superior vena cava and into your
heart.
So, drug molecules that are
absorbed in your mouth bypass
the liver and they go directly
to your--the rest of your body
first.
Then of course they're going to
end up in the liver as things
get circulated around.
They avoid going to the liver
the first time and that's
called, here on this graph,
avoiding first-pass metabolism
in the liver.
This metabolism that occurs on
the first shot right from the
intestine is called first-pass
metabolism.
Nitroglycerin would be very
readily broken down in the
liver.
So this way it goes directly to
the heart without ever having to
pass through the liver and it
can quickly treat heart disease.
Now, why don't you do that
with all sorts of things?
Well, it only works for certain
kinds of compounds,
compounds that can be absorbed
through those membranes in your
mouth so they have to very lipid
soluble.
They also have to be very
potent because one difference
between your mouth and the
intestine is that the surface
area in your mouth is fairly
small.
Only a limited number of drugs
can absorb through,
whereas--why is your intestine
so long?
You know that your
intestinal--you took it out and
stretched it out it would be a
tube, a continuous tube,
that's about 30 feet long.
Why is your intestine that
long, packed into this small
space?
So that it can have a big
surface area to absorb lots of
stuff;
big surface area--lots of
absorption, small surface
area--little absorption.
It has to be a very potent drug
in order to be absorbed at a
sufficient concentration through
this limited space.
I think those are the main
concepts that I wanted to
introduce by thinking about
these different methods of
administration.
There's more of them listed
here, some of them have to do
with what Caitlin mentioned.
If you want a drug that works
in the eye, for example,
a drug to treat glaucoma,
why take a drug orally and
expose your whole body to the
drug when you could just put
drops in your eye directly?
And that's how many glaucoma
drugs are delivered?
You might have eye drops that
you just put into the space
underneath your eye,
for example,
and that's a more targeted
delivery.
Targeted because you are
putting the drug at the site
where it's needed.
I'm sure you have examples of
that;
topical ointments like
antibacterial cream you might
put on something if you have a
cut and you want to keep it from
being infected.
You don't take antibiotics by
mouth and have them all over
your body, you put a little
topical treatment on the site
because you're targeting the
drug to the site that you need.
On the next slide there's
some other more uncommon modes
of administration,
rectal, transdermal,
vaginal.
We won't talk very much about
those, and next week we'll talk
about special kinds of drug
delivery systems that are useful
for certain kinds of
administration like what are
called controlled release
implants,
we'll talk about next time.
I want--I've given you a lot of
words and I've tried to
introduce a lot of concepts by
thinking about things that you
know about.
I want to try to put this in
some framework that allows you
to think about quantitatively
what it means--what these
factors mean.
We're going to introduce drugs
into a patient and what we would
like to know is how rapidly do
those drugs become available,
what fraction of the drugs
become available,
and how long does the one dose
we give last?
As I mentioned,
that's complicated,
complicated because our anatomy
is complicated,
and complicated because we're
all different individuals and
our anatomy and physiology
differs.
So, it's a hard thing to,
do to describe how even one
particular kind of drug acts in
a population of people is
difficult.
We have to start somewhere
so we're going to start with a
simplification.
That simplification is that
these complex
things--people--can be
represented by very simple
constructs.
The simple construct that I
show here is that instead of a
person we're going to consider
the person to be a well stirred
vat of liquid,
water for example.
Now, how can you get away with
that?
Well, one to say you can get
away with it is that we are
mostly water,
our bodies are 90% water and so
if you wanted to describe us
sort of in the simplest possible
way we're water,
that's largely what we are.
We're structured water with a
particular kind of shape and
form, but we're largely water.
We could describe where
drugs go in the body by just
thinking about how they dissolve
in water.
All you'd need to know is,
'What's the volume of the
water?'
So, if I give a dose what
concentration do you get,
I give ten milligrams.
If your volume is five liters,
what's the concentration you
achieve inside?
What did I say?
Ten milligrams?
I forgot what number I said
now, ten milligrams divided by
five liters, two milligrams per
liter.
That's the concentration and
that's the simplest way to
define it.
Now, how can I get away with
saying that we're well-stirred?
I indicate that in this simple
drawing by having a--this is a
propeller that's stirring the
vat of liquid,
how can I get away with saying
we're well-stirred?
Well, in some senses we are,
that's what our circulatory
system does, and I'm going to
talk about that in the weeks to
come,
but our heart is a very
effective--our heart and our
blood vessels are a very
effective system for
distributing molecules very
rapidly throughout a large
volume and so we are stirred--we
are well-stirred in certain
senses.
Now, you could object to
this simple model for lots of
different reasons but we're
going to start with it because
it's a very simple place to
start.
We're going to say then when we
administer a drug we're
introducing a drug into this
well stirred vat of water that
has a particular volume.
We're going to administer some
dose and we're going to produce
some concentration.
Now, what happens afterwards?
Does that concentration stay
the same forever?
No, it doesn't because we--our
body has mechanisms for getting
rid of drugs.
We're going to describe that in
our simple model by having an
arrow pointing out that tells
you how--that tells you that
drugs are eliminated when
they're within your body.
We're going to make this a
very simple process also and say
that drugs are eliminated in
proportion to their
concentration.
The more drug you have the
faster it gets eliminated,
and as you have less and less
drug it gets eliminated more
slowly.
Now, this--the simplest way to
describe this is to say that the
rate of disappearance of a drug
is equal to some constant times
the concentration.
The rate of disappearance of a
drug is equal to some constant
times the concentration.
This constant is called a rate
constant and this is the
concentration that would be
within the body.
This is a first-order equation.
Means that the rate at which
the drug is eliminated is
proportional to concentration to
the first-power or linear with
concentration.
As drug concentration goes
down, since k is a
constant for any particular
drug.
It's one number,
as the concentration drops from
two milligrams per liter to one
milligram per liter,
the rate that your body
eliminates it goes down by half
as well.
I like to think about this
as you could think about
concentration as money in your
wallet,
and the rate at which I spend
money anyway is proportional to
the amount that I have in my
wallet;
when I have more I spend more,
when I have less I spend less,
and the last dollar goes really
slowly.
The same thing here,
when you have a lot of
concentration your body gets rid
of it fast, but the last
molecules go out very slowly.
If we take this simple model
and then apply it,
and we introduce a dose
directly into the body,
now this well-stirred vat,
and we say that it has some
volume and we say that drug is
eliminated with some rate
constant k,
we could derive a simple
equation.
This is derived in the book,
in the box at the back of the
chapter, that would tell us how
concentration varies with time
and that equation is shown here.
The concentration is equal to
the dose that I introduced which
is M_0 divided
by the volume of the body,
times e^(-kt),
where k is this rate
constant for disappearance of
the drug;
C = (M_0/V)*
e^(-kt).
Now, if you don't
understand when you look at the
book where this equation comes
from,
that's not important.
Some of you will and some of
you won't, but you could trust
me that this is the equation
that results from those simple
assumptions that I talked about.
C is the concentration
that's available in your
bloodstream or in this vat of
fluid, that's available for
action.
M_0 is the
amount that's introduced,
and remember I introduced it in
a special way,
I injected it right into the
body.
I injected it all into the
body, the whole dose at time
t equals 0.
I introduced it all into the
body at once so it was all
available to circulate.
That assumes the
bioavailability is 100% and that
I've introduced it all at one
particular time.
What is this really a
representation of?
It's a representation of
intravenous injection where I
have syringe and I inject all of
the drug at once.
In that case,
what this equation tells you is
that the concentration
immediately after you inject the
drug is the highest,
and after that it continually
goes down.
It goes down in an exponential
fashion with a time course that
depends on this constant
k.
Does that make sense?
If I have intravenous
administration of a drug that's
eliminated by a first-order
process, as soon as I administer
it, the concentration is a peak.
After that it goes down and the
rate at which it goes down
depends on this rate constant
k.
What I also show you here is
that if I plugged into this
equation I asked the question,
'When does the concentration go
down by a factor of two,
when does it go down by 50%?'
I would look on this graph here
and say 50% of the drug is gone
by this time.
I could calculate that time at
which the drug concentration
goes down by half and that's
equal to the ln(2/k),
this rate constant here,
so when this number is smaller
the half life is longer.
Molecules with a high
k are eliminated rapidly;
molecules with a low k
are eliminated slowly.
That half-life is a good
measure of how long the drug
activity lasts in your body;
it's a good way of thinking
about how long I'd have to wait
before I needed another dose,
for example.
What this graph shows you here
is just plotted on a semi-log
plot.
The difference between these
curbs, if I had drugs with
different half-life,
a drug with a half-life of 600
minutes last a long time;
concentration doesn't drop
until a long time,
it has many,
many hours.
If it has a half-life of 60
minutes, concentration drops to
10% of its initial level after a
few hours.
If I have a drug with the
half-life of six minutes
concentration drops to 10% of
its initial level after only a
few minutes.
So, we're going to take this
model and extend it next time
and talk about more complicated
modes of administration and talk
about sort of new forms of drug
delivery,
forms that you can expect to
see in the next few years.